let's get some analysis from republican
senator arc of arkansas tom cotton
senator you heard what the president had
to say you were critical of him earlier
today for a tepid response he's clearly
upped it a bit to blocking sanctions on
russian banks including their military
bank is that enough
no john unfortunately it's not uh enough
i mean at least it's a step in the right
direction um i wouldn't even call it
half measure though it's probably more
like a quarter measure sanctions on a
couple banks and some oligarchs
i've been calling for months now
for the kind of punishing sanctions that
joe biden and western leaders keep
promising but never revealing
permanently cancelling the nordstrom 2
pipeline not just shuffling some
bureaucratic paper around its review
imposing sanctions on russia's oil and
gas sectors its mineral and mining
sectors the critical
industries in that country clamping down
on its financial industry and its access
to the international banking systems
these are the kind of sanctions that are
called for now uh not these quarter
measures that were just announced or
that berlin announced earlier today
about nordstrom 2. i mean unfortunately
the administration spent the first 24
hours
debating whether to even call this
invasion an invasion
and the president took 80 minutes to
come out for his own press conference
which doesn't exactly project confidence
and certainty and resolution to people
watching in moscow so so much more is
called for right now john than what we
just heard okay so we'll see if that
happens uh the president said to put it
simply russia just announced that it is
carving out a big chunk of ukraine
saying very definitively to your point
on the wavering of whether this was an
invasion or not saying this is the
beginning of a russia invasion of
ukraine and then announced i'm going to
begin to impose sanctions that go beyond
those implemented in 2014.
do you believe anything there that the
president said will bother the kremlin
senator
again sandra i'm afraid not even that
phrasing that he used the beginning of
invasion it is an invasion it's not the
beginning of anything it's an invasion
vladimir putin and russia's leaders have
made clear that they view not just the
territory under the control of the proxy
military forces they've been backing for
eight years is now separate from ukraine
but territory that ukraine controls
that's why they're putting heavy armored
uh soldiers and vehicles and weapons
into those two provinces in eastern
ukraine because they prepare they're
preparing to invade even deeper into
ukraine that's why they have all those
troops stationed
in belarus just north of the capital
city of key that's why they have so many
of their navy ships in the black sea to
seize the black sea coast
ukraine has been invaded president biden
and his western counterparts promised
for months swift and severe sanctions
when that happened and in the first 24
hours that's not what we've seen it's
far from what we've seen and i suspect
vladimir putin is going to be emboldened
to take further aggression against
ukraine so senator
the president's threat was if you go in
further incursions or further invasion
of ukraine we're going to hit you with
more sanctions so
maybe vladimir putin sees the light
let's just say
for talking purposes here he sees the
light says you know i'm not going to
invade the rest of ukraine but how do
you get him out of where he is now
they tried to get him out of crimea he
wouldn't budge his response was to annex
the place
what's to stop him from doing the same
thing in there and donetsk and luhansk
can say okay that's it that's as far as
i'm going but i'm never leaving
well john unfortunately i just don't
think he will see the light uh that
he can already see the kind of timid
response that the west has mounted the
prime minister of italy mario draghi
just a couple days ago said that we
shouldn't have any sanctions on russia's
energy sector because italy is almost as
beholden to russia as germany is for its
energy exports that's why it's so
important that we put those sanctions on
the table now at least at a minimum
announce what they will be
even if they don't have the political
will to impose them now because the
silence to vladimir putin is deafening
he can see the internal divisions among
the west and he is going to continue to
exploit those divisions
uh what also struck me and something
that we talked about in advance of the
president's words was what he will say
to reassure americans that this conflict
and this invasion over there won't run
up prices much more here what he's doing
about it he said we're closely
monitoring energy suppliers around the
world and i'm thinking
we're one of them and we have shown that
we are able to supply the amount of
energy we need in this country we are
not doing that today to the point where
we are now importing oil from foreign
nations including russia so why not a
stronger message there to the american
people what we're going to do to make
sure that those prices don't keep going
up
why didn't he announce that we're going
to start pumping more oil
well sandra unfortunately prices at the
pump probably are going to go up but
remember they were going up for the
first year of the biden administration
long before this moment that inflation
is a direct result
of the hostility that the bite
administration really the progressive
left in america has towards oil and gas
which still powers our economy as much
as they might not like that what we need
to do is to continue to invest more in
american oil and gas production take off
all the regulatory red tape in terms of
producing oil and gas here the might
administration has reimposed over the
last year otherwise the left is taking
us down the path of germany which built
all those pipelines to russia which
closed down all of its nuclear power
plants and now they are beholden to a
hostile foreign power that's the last
place america should ever be especially
since we don't have to be there since
we're blessed with so much oil and gas
in this country to use for our own
safety and our own prosperity okay
senator tom cotton with reaction to the
president's remarks thank you senator
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else